[Music]
with so much on their plates
busy people rely on shortcuts to help
repair meals
nowadays you can stock your pantry with
cans of pre-cooked meat
so there's always something on hand to
use in sandwiches
stews stir fries and other tasty dishes
this canned meat is meticulously hand
produced
by a craft cannery and made in small
batches
it contains no artificial ingredients or
preservatives
just meat and sea salt when a shipment
of meat arrives at the cannery
the quality control manager records its
lot code for tracking purposes
as a food safety precaution he confirms
the temperature of the meat
which must come in between 0 to 39
degrees fahrenheit
a skilled butcher then inspects the meat
and trims off the excess fat
if it's a large piece the butcher slices
it into smaller pieces
so that it can pass through the dicing
machine
the dicer cuts the meat into one-inch
[Music]
cubes
at the filling station aluminum cans
circulate around a rotating table
as one worker shovels cubed meat onto
the center of the table
others manually fill cans while
simultaneously
performing a quality inspection workers
will discard any cubes that are
discolored or too fatty
next technicians place a single cube of
sea salt
in each can filled with meat
this is the only added ingredient
at the next station workers weigh each
can individually
and either add or remove meat to reach
the required weight
the filled cans now travel on a conveyor
belt to the cook room
[Music]
there they enter the preheater which
blasts them with steam for 20 seconds
this expels air that's trapped between
the cubes of meat
next the cans move into the closing
machine
the machine compresses the meat to
provide sufficient clearance at the top
of the can
this headspace creates a vacuum on the
can
to draw out the remaining air
then a device attaches the lid by a
process known as double seaming
the process rolls the edges of the lid
and can together
forming a rim that provides an airtight
seal
it's time to get cooking a worker lowers
the cans into a commercial-sized
pressure cooker
cooking under steam pressure produces
the tenderizing effects of slow cooking
in a fraction of the time
the meat cooks in its own juices the
cooking temperature varies depending on
the type of meat and the can size
when the meat is ready the technician
removes the cans
and sets them aside for about an hour to
cool and dry
the cans are then moved to the packaging
area
as a worker loads the labeling machine
he inspects each can for dense
or damaged seals
one by one the cans roll over a glue
applicator
then a stack of labels wrapping
themselves in the top seal
at the same time the machine counts the
number of cans
[Music]
after rolling off the labeling machine
the cans pass through an inkjet printer
which applies the best used by date
that date is next to the lot code which
the closing machine printed while
attaching the lid
this can of meat has a five year shelf
life due to two crucial factors
it is cooked properly and the can seal
is airtight